we've talked about is the future a return to
the sort of McCain Romney wing of the Republican
Party? Is the future a Trump in Q Cunanan type
dominated Republican Party? Is it a fractured
party where someone goes off and takes their toys
home, meaning Trump leaves the party and starts
his own or more traditional Republican parties
leave the party and start their own? And the
answer is we just don't know yet. As we talked
about Donald Trump announcing at his CPAC speech
at the end of February that he wants Republicans
not to donate to the party, but to donate to his
PAC and he will decide which Republicans to
primary because they're bad Republicans and
on the other hand, which Republicans to support,
basically because they support Donald Trump. OK,
speaking on the debut episode of The Lisa
Boothe Show, Donald Trump was interviewed
and named names as to who he believes is the
future of the Republican Party. And it's mostly
just people that suck up to Trump. I don't
think it'll be surprising to you to hear that
the people that Donald Trump believes are the
future of the Republican Party include Florida
Governor Ronda Santurce, who from the beginning
of the coronavirus pandemic resisted doing
anything in Florida. Kowtowed to Trump, placated
Trump kept as much open for as long as possible.
Trump says Ron DeSantis is part of the future of
the Republican Party. Senators Josh Hawley, Ted
Cruz and Rand Paul. You'll remember that back in
the 2016 Republican primary, Trump and Cruz didn't
really get along. Cruz saying some ugly things
about Trump, Trump literally implying that Ted
Cruz's wife is ugly. So a lot of ugly there. But
ultimately, Ted Cruz came around to Donald Trump,
Rand Paul, Major Trump. Brownnoser became a
friend of Trump's during the campaign during the
presidency, playing golf with Trump. Josh Holley,
arguably the most prominent senator who on January
6th tried to actually prevent the electoral votes
from being counted. So we know why they are there.
South Dakota Governor Kristi Noem, she has been
a big Trump suck up to some degree. Maybe she's
on the list because Trump finds her attractive.
That's always a possibility with Donald Trump
as well. And then, of course, Arkansas Republican
gubernatorial candidate Sarah Huckabee Sanders a
massive Trump suck up who has importantly remained
loyal after she left the administration. Remember
that Sarah Huckabee Sanders was Donald Trump's
press secretary for some period of time. So these
are the people Trump says are the future. He said,
quote, I think we have a lot of people. We have a
lot of young good people. Ronda Santos is doing a
really good job in Florida. Josh Holley has shown
real courage in going after big tech. You know,
they go after him. Josh is terrific. Somebody
that's been really terrific is Ted Cruz. Trump
said he and I had it out for a while. Actually,
we were very close even during the campaign,
and then it got nasty. The press would say,
when's the nastiness going to start? I said, don't
worry, it'll start. And it got very violent. But
he's been great, essentially meaning eventually
Ted Cruz just prayed at the altar of Trump
and then Trump mentioning a few other names and
saying he's very confident in the talent pool,
calling the Republican Party stacked,
stacked. So the strategy here is very clear.
If Trump can be a successful kingmaker in
2022 and decide who gets primaried and loses
and decide who he backs, who gets reelected, if
he can effectively pick the winners and losers
in twenty twenty two, it better positions him for
twenty twenty four. He was asked in this interview
with Lisa Boothe whether whether and when
he will decide about throwing his hat in
the ring. He just didn't say anything about
it yet. And it seems very, very clear that
if Trump fails to control the party in 2022, he's
unlikely to run. And I think even if he succeeds,
he may not run because he'll just be, you
know, older, tired or bored with the idea.
By 2024, if Trump successfully runs the
twenty twenty two primary, in particular,
if the people he chooses helped to take control
back of the House or Senate from Democrats in
twenty twenty two, I think at least Trump will be
able to make the case that he is still the most
powerful figure in the party and may run in twenty
twenty for the names on Trump's list. Not hugely
surprising. Whether Trump will succeed at this in
twenty twenty two certainly remains to be seen.